أجنبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أجنبية
[موسيقى] أماكن
[موسيقى]
كنت أحزمها الآن أنا الآن في
المدرسة الابتدائية
التي أعرف أنها تدعمها اليوم هناك مع عائلتي.
إنه لأمر
محزن للغاية للغاية هذا أمر خطير
الوضع
فقط الله سيأتي إلى مكان ما هذا اليوم
الآن إذا لم أكن أعرف ،
نعم ، لا أعرف رأيي الآن هو أنني
أحبطت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى
] الأموال التي يدفعونها لي عندما  أنا أتقاعد هو
ما أتخذه لبناء هذا المنزل الآن
ليس لدي أي شيء ،
لذا أرجوك أريد من الحكومة الفيدرالية أن
تفعل شيئًا حيال هذا الفيضان ،
فإنها ستنشئ السد
[موسيقى] ،
نحتاج حقًا إلى المساعدة من
الحكومة
التي نحتاجها للمساعدة
لأنها ليست رغبتنا في ذلك  ها
هي المياه التي تطاردنا بعيدًا
وفقدنا أشياء كثيرة أثناء الفيضان ،
شكرًا لك